I don't remember Dickie was a good one
that's my favorite one slap small dick
you yeah great that's great that was a
great version of that but do you think a
lot of people's dick grows as they all
right when do you think a guy's dick
stops growing a bet probably in their
60s or 70s or 80s that's false you think
can you look at it please do I did see a
change when I dated a guy in high school
his dick was much bigger when I saw him
again years after Wow who's seeing guys
dicks in a high school and I was you
know this is why I have an iPod Filipino
does it believe that if you see a dick
you're not supposed to see you get a
thigh oh really
yeah oh wow that's pretty cool who did
you see baby Oh our dog oh thanks always
out was it yeah what's wrong he doesn't
have like a cap on it
he has a cap on it it's just not a tight
cap by the time you reach 18 or 19 years
old your penis isn't likely to grow much
longer or thicker [ __ ] bro I'm
thinking about getting a dick reduction
dang that's not even true music is a pig
it's pretty it's definitely it's growing
what it's because you have masturbated
in like 90 days who's grown before that
it's fluid it's come juice I don't know
what it is man but it better it better
hear me now and get its act together
yeah okay yeah I raised my voice yeah my
dick has been like that's I guess that
Justin's 1819 yeah Mac's 1819 yeah but I
never looked at my dick I went yeah
there you go yeah all right I said hi
and then you know make and the dick is
so dumb I think it's you know whatever
get in these pants and the whole idea of
having sex and procreation your dick
your dick is therefore it dictates so
much of your [ __ ] life in
decision-making yeah I almost wish that
which is no an issue yeah
male you dictate Africa dude that's what
I would do feed a couple of starving
families her feet are starving our two
kids that are split
a quick snack after a game yeah yeah
it's nap that's it one kid a meal yeah
it's like a bag of like you know oh you
want to grind it down yeah grab my dick
down yet yeah dick dick tip yeah Bob is
dick dip yeah but you know what um a lot
of times it's intrusive your penis yeah
yeah and I've made you know why do you
buy cologne what are you doing better
yeah I mean long you know Raya Raya yeah
but you're always trying to impress
somebody
it's like [ __ ] man yeah okay or
you're getting like little things put
near your dick to like take the
attention away from your dick if your
dick isn't like a good size it doesn't
look like big cards you get like a like
a big car tattooed on your thigh [ __ ]
big car yeah yeah next thing you know
they're just have a small dick they're
married to a small I was thinking about
getting a tattoo of my on my dick of a
bigger dick oh wow you think that would
work
yeah you could do it I guess you'd have
to I don't know how you would do it you
need extra canvas Yeah right I don't
have it yeah you gotta get you got a
yeah
but let me say this so is there like
some sort of like like can I use CGI you
use light music cuz things that are
lighter look bigger yeah put your Tanner
you look that's why you look like you
have a pale dick yeah you could tan the
area around your day and just light in
the middle part that's true you don't
even need to tan your dick you just can
the surroundings it's just like my why
my teeth are so white when I'm tan yeah
oh yeah it's it's not because they're
any whiter it's just because I'm tanner
yeah Michael just look whiter than this
bigger bigger your teeth a little bigger
when you smile when you have a tan why
but they do look more engaging your dick
look more engaging
that's what okay what's the reason why
you you shave right yeah to give the
appearance that there's more yeah yeah I
[ __ ] yeah I have been shaving because it
just feels you know like I can say hi oh
yeah you look a lot better when you
shave yeah yeah and most guys do you
look like Scary kids don't cry when they
see like a baby will cry if you have a
lot of hair on your face yeah whose
biggest digger George or Bryce whose
biggest digger your biggest digger
know who honestly well I'm gonna say
this so Georgia is that straight a
mullet coming in and have you have you
seen George penis has he seen yours
you've seen George's penis I've seen
right his penis yeah oh yeah I have -
I've never seen his let me I see
something and be honest both of you who
has a bigger dick no it's flaccid then
who has a bigger flat yeah that's true
that's me there really is a difference
really oh really I can tell that guys
got a real ha Duraflame yeah we've seen
a sticking his dick is big your dick is
okay because my dick is definitely
bigger than mine
but I think that Bryce probably has a
bigger dick Bryce seems like a guy who
definitely brings it big dick - like a
knife fight you know no knife we're on
the man just that's all yeah
and that's crazy and dude you should get
your act together yeah you definitely
seem like somebody could be like a Ted
Bundy but an athletic one Center you
could have played Center on Ted Bundy's
basketball you guys can't see him the
guy with the big one of George's family
members who knows how big each other's
dicks are he's a very tall guy